perspective today thanks for inviting me
tim um
so yeah i'm going to talk about learning
it in games
learning in equilibrium um today i'm
going to talk about static games which
are the games probably
more familiar to computer science
audience these are games which player
takes a single action
all the players move simultaneously you
know think of
matching pennies or rock stages paper
battle of the sexes
then tomorrow i'll talk about extensive
form games
where the strategies players use aren't
actions but are complete
um contingent plans and because this is
a little
um outside sort of the stuff
a lot of cs people are familiar with i'm
a slightly different approach in this
talk than some of the past ones to give
you a bit more sort of motivation
and world view um and
a little bit of core techniques and
models and
not so so much on on recent stuff we'll
see how the time goes
so what's the motivation for this whole
project from the viewpoint of economics
well we like to look at nash equilibria
for predicting things
but rationality isn't really a good
explanation
for why we might see nash equilibrium
it's neither
it's not sufficient because in a game
with multiple nash equilibrium
you can have all the rationality
assumptions you want and it won't
explain
why the people play in equilibrium
unless you can explain why everyone
is focused on the same equilibrium it's
also not necessary
either theoretically or empirically you
can write down
evolutionary models like the replicator
dynamic which can converge to nash
equilibria
and empirically colonies of bacteria can
converge to nash equilibria and sort of
standard economic definitions of
rationality
wouldn't you go so far as to bacteria
computation maybe but
rationality no so
uh the learning theoretic explanation is
that when we see equilibrium in a game
it arises as the result of some sort of
non-equilibrium
adaptive process okay so that's that's
the
the um the world view the
starting point and there's some you know
evidence in support of this if you look
at
play in game theory experiments it does
converge to nash equilibrium
in a reasonable time frame not in all
games
but in some games of interest to
economists including car no duopoly
which people may
have seen in undergraduate classes
voluntary contribution games
the beauty contest games and the double
auctions that are sometimes used to
explain um how prices are set
in competitive equilibrium models
here's just some if we don't know one of
those games
it doesn't matter at all this is and i'm
not going to explain them i will i will
show you two
pictures so this is this this is a graph
of an experiment
by vest on it all this is a game where
there's a public good and you can put in
some money we all get a benefit
you know how much how much do you put in
and they ran this
um for two different parameter values
one zero one six it doesn't matter what
matters is for both these games
the nash equilibrium was for everyone to
give three
and you see what happens that you shall
play in a lab issue a bunch of people in
the lab
and you anonymously pair them up or four
player game put them in fours to play
the game
they play once see what happens and you
rematch them so there's play
of a static game over and over with
rematching and the first time here
people played the game
they're up like four and a half that's
not really three but then this is what
happens as people played the game more
and more
play converged to three okay
um in this other game it looked like
play started off
more or less at nash equilibrium and
kind of stayed there
a game people may have heard of as the
beauty contest game
where you know guess everyone names a
number and the winner is closest to
two-thirds the average or two-thirds the
median
so here's um results from an experim
experimental player this game with nash
equilibrium was
zero and you see the first time people
play the
bids are far from equilibrium and
they're decreasing towards equilibrium
over time
so that's the kind of picture i'd like
to have you have in mind when
equilibrium occurs it's because of this
sort of
convergence 2 equilibrium
so when and why might that happen we're
going to look at the long run behavior
of some non-equilibrium dynamic please
yes people it's the same game but you
don't play with the same partner so
importantly in these games
you have like 30 people in the lab to
play your game and you play a different
person each time
the reason for that is we don't want to
say people are playing a 30 period
repeated game
they're playing 30 iterations of the
same
two-player game with different people
so we look at convergence equilibrium
a lot of ways that could happen there's
a lot of adjustment processes that can
converge to equilibrium
i want to talk about learning um what do
i mean
well i don't want to tell you what i
mean in a by the word learning because
it's too squishy
people have said that things of
that look like evolution involve
quote-unquote learning and there are
you know there's all sorts of gray line
cases is it learning or not so if
everyone sees the state of a system what
everyone is doing and you can be matched
with someone to play tomorrow
is that this could be adaptation is that
learning yes maybe not
what if you don't see the state of the
system you get a noisy signal of the
state of the system and you know
is it learning so this all i don't want
to get
really hung up on exactly what's
learning what's not i'm going to focus
on a particular
stylized model of learning today okay
very narrow sense of learning the models
i
think about but as models of learning
are models that explicitly say how each
individual
agent uses their observations to change
their behavior
as opposed to what as opposed you could
write down
a mean field you write down behavior of
the aggregate
and you can't tell what people are doing
maybe you could
go off in a corner and look at a model
of individual agents and build a model
of learning that leads this aggregate
system maybe not okay so just as part of
methodology i'm gonna look at systems
where
i'm to take it i'm going to describe
what individual people are doing
the agents i want you to think about are
self-interested at each
time step they're doing what they think
is good for them
that's the natural thing for economists
it's different if you're like uh
a system designer and you're designing a
bunch of distributed nodes and you want
them to cooperate with each other
you can make them want to play
equilibrium that's not our case we're
looking at people
self-interested people okay
for those of you who know the the the
literature the rules i want you to think
about are what
heart muscle call uncoupled we want the
rule the player
one uses in learning how to play the
game not to depend on
the details of player two's payoff
function and player two's learning role
there's portable rules players could
plop down anywhere
and go and i'm gonna talk about the
performance of the rules
some rules will perform well in some
cases poorly and others some perform you
know pretty badly all the time
but the performance of the rule is not
going to be my
main point of interest i'm going to use
performance of rules as a guide to
plausibility of rules
really badly performing rules we'd say
maybe people wouldn't use them
but if the rule you know sometimes
performs badly but
badly in a way that we think people
actually do that won't bother me
okay so i'm not looking for the best
rule
in any sense some common themes in this
literature
we want to explain equilibrium so we're
doing non-equilibrium adjustment
okay well it's pointless to explain how
we got to equilibrium and say battle of
the sexes
by saying here's a multi-period dynamic
game
assume equilibrium in the big game and
look it gets equilibrium in the small
game all we've done is we've pushed the
y equilibrium question one step higher
up so that's a very simple obvious point
okay the reason i'm bothering to make it
is because
people who knock their heads at this
don't always immediately grasp the
contrapositive
which is if we accept
we're not going to insist on equilibrium
in this dynamic process
we have to accept our priori
that some of our agents may have dynamic
rules
that aren't the best possible rule they
could be using given the rules of the
others
so people the agents are making a
mistake the rules not
optimal why not well what's the negation
of that
if every player's rule is the best
response to the rule of the others in
this dynamic world we've got an
equilibrium
in and why okay we don't want to swim
equilibrium
players might be making mistakes so then
if you point out to me oh one of your
guys is making a
you could do better that on its own
won't be interesting to me as a critique
of a model
so the interesting question is not
whether the
learning rule can generate some optimal
play
but whether players would notice this so
if it's not enough there'd be something
you could do that's better
it has to be something easy to notice
and not too hard if it's a simple
obvious improvement that would bother me
it's okay people shouldn't be that dumb
but the mere existence of an improvement
not a thing
i'm going to focus on long-run play
please eva
don't you have to define simple for this
sentence to make sense
it's going to be a judgment call and i'm
not so i have anything formal yet
when i do formal things i'll make formal
definitions okay
um as
uh christos alluded to
i guess yesterday you write down a
general dynamical system
you're not convert you're not guaranteed
it will converge so convergence
equilibrium
is not guaranteed some games will have
convergence some not
um
a bit this question about in the lab you
play different people each day
we're going to look think of settings
where people um
oh i should have this is a leftover
editing
error but people are going to play
repeatedly without playing a repeated
game
because they'll play a different partner
each day ignore this sentence
learning depends on what the players
observe when they
play the game we can look at different
observation structures
it also will depend on whether players
actions change what they observe
if your action has no impact on what you
see then the only question each day is
what's
going to give me a good payoff call that
passive learning
the opposite case active learning
your action influences a signal
distribution that will be relevant
tomorrow when i talk about extensive
form games
criteria for learning roles well if i
could go to the lab
and measure people's learning rules and
say here's the three learning rules
everyone in the world uses
i wouldn't need criteria i just have
these three these three rules and we
just use those it turns out it's very
hard to go to the lab
and pin down the exact rules people use
there's lots of noise
in paper individual agents there's a lot
of people trying to look at this it's
complicated so we're gonna have some
combination of
simplicity plausibility and portability
as conditions for the rules start with
really simple rules
and add complications you know as needed
that seem important to
capture major departures of
the data from the rules we start with
so if we can't make an empirical
question how do we pick
you know what helps us guide
plausibility other than data
different criteria in the literature one
that's
perhaps more familiar to computer
scientists or most economists
is the use of worst case or min max
considerations like
no regret learning the thing that
economics grad students are you know
would intuitively write down as the
first model is a model of a
a bayesian rational agent with a prior
maximizing expected utility that's the
dominant paradigm in economics
a third alternative is what i'll call
boundedly rational or behavioral
i'll just write down a rule and say i
like this rule let's see what it does
okay so with these three different
criteria
um we'll see there's not necessarily
such
tight boundaries between these these
aren't
this isn't a disjoint set this is a
partition of the rules
okay so let me talk next about a very
simple stylized model of learning
that'll be
useful workhorse in literature it'll
help me present some basic
ideas we can then think about how to
complicate it up once we understand it
because fictitious play an odd name
given that i'm using these models to
describe actual behavior when when this
model was first written down by brown
he did not view it as a descriptive
model this is viewed as a way of
computing equilibrium
hence fictitious play but it's now used
as a simple descriptive model of
learning
it's easy to motivate and analyze i
think
um it's too simple to match the
experimental data and i'll comment some
on
the most important things that leaves
out you might want to add in
and it's a foundation for more
complicated learning models so what's
the motivation
have our agent she's going to repeatedly
play the same strategic form game day
after day
and she knows the structure of the game
say knows the
game matrix although that can be relaxed
and there's extensions of the fictitious
played
cases where people know the shape of the
matrix but not the entries and so on but
for now let's say people know the game
matrix
the thing the agent doesn't know is
what's the other side going to do are
they going to play heads half the time
or heads two-thirds of the time or
what's the probability the next guy meet
place heads okay
all the agent observes that the outcome
of play in their own matches
doesn't get to observe what happens in
other people's matches
or opponents past play all you know i'm
playing someone today you don't get to
see their whole life history
when you play with them the agent
believes she's playing against a
randomly drawn
member from a large population and so
each day when she takes her action
she takes the action that maximizes
today's expected payoff
that's what i call strategic myopia as
opposed to what in a repeated game
if i'm going to play you tomorrow i want
to might take my action today thinking
about how my today's action
will change your action tomorrow okay
that's not strategic myopia that's
foresight so
these guys you're playing a different
guy every day there's no point in
giving up money today to make the person
be nice to you tomorrow you'll never see
them again
okay myopia because what the agent
observes is independent of what they do
there's no reason to change your action
to buy more information
you're going to see what your opponent
does regardless
so we have a case where there's no need
to experiment or what i call
passive learning does the strategic
myopia
condition kind of rule out the
development of social norms
we should be nice to each other this
kind of thing
um
it seems to be designed to rule out like
yeah so so yeah yes so the
the today i'm looking at one-shot games
and that's true that it's going to rule
this out so
you could um i'll talk about extensive
forum games tomorrow
one particular kind of extensive forum
game is a repeated game
and there it's perfectly possible that
we'll have these norms so i'd be nice to
you because you'll be nice to me later
the simplest repeated game is just two
players same two players each day
but you could also have some social
repeated game with this
non-infinite population of 100 people
and you play different people
and i know that if i'm mean to you today
you'll go and tell all my friends and
i'll
be mean to me tomorrow so um all those
things can be accommodated but i'd argue
they don't really belong in static games
they belong
their equilibrium phenomena in extensive
games that's more of a topic for
tomorrow
okay so fictitious play goes beyond
these two things
and implicitly supposes says the agents
act as if they are basians
facing a stationary unknown distribution
of opponent strategies
they think the world is constant
okay um the stationarity they think the
world is constant i argue that's a
plausible first hypothesis
in many situations absent evidence to
the contrary you might think
today is like yesterday so you might
think people would stick with it if it's
more or less right
but if you give people really strong
evidence that it's wrong
you might think they'd notice so if your
opponent is playing heads tails heads
tails heads tails heads tails
you know the empirical frequency of
heads is converging to a half pretty
quickly but you might actually notice
there's a two cycle
so it's it's not okay um or in that
beauty contest game
where people play they started off at 40
40 30 20 10. if you're in a gamer each
day
but the mean of everyone's play is
getting lower and lower
you might notice that after a few
periods and you might not expect that
tomorrow looks like today
okay so this isn't going to fit all
situations
if it's some situations
what does it mean for a beijing to think
the world is stationary
or you know thinks his draws are
exchangeable
that means that he thinks every
observation is just as informative if
the world is constant
then data from last year is just as good
as data from yesterday
okay so every observation gets equal
weight
so in that sense beliefs are
asymptotically empirical
meaning they converge to the empirical
distribution
as people get more uh
data and one of the things i'll talk
about at the end if there's time so one
of the sort of
wedges between this model and what seems
to happen in the lab
at least in some settings in the lab
people seem to give less weight to older
data
than to new data so it's as if
implicitly they think the world is
changing okay
this is what psychologists call recency
bias
okay that's not that's being ruled out
here we can we can talk about how to add
this in
if there's time so
that was all very high level description
of fictitious play so
brown didn't talk about bayesians
updating he just wrote down a rule
this is a rules you call it behavioral
abound the rational here's the rule
each player i starts off with the weight
function that gives a weight to each
opponent's strategy
it's a none number
and the updating rule is simple every
period you see what your opponent did
and you add one to the weight on the
thing your opponent did
okay then at any time
you say what's the probability i think
my opponent plays heads
i'll look at the current weight on heads
divided by the sum of the weights
that's the probability i think my
opponent place heads so i
can do this for each strategy i get an
imputed
strategy vector for my opponent a mixed
strategy i play a best response to it
that's the rule fictitious play okay so
brown wrote this down just directly
as a rule it looks very you know crude
um
why might you do this well
i said people are bayesian how is this
abation with this invasion with a
particular prior
um if you're a basin who has a duraclay
distribution
over the mixed
strategies in the population this is
exactly the update rule that you'll use
okay so
methodological point this rule was
written down sort of
to compute stuff in the 50s you could
look at it in the 60s as
behavioral about i'm just looking at the
rule so it turns out it's
it's bayesian and and not for even a
screwy prior for pretty standard
textbook
prior okay so it's not a bright line
between
boundaries rational and bayesian
especially
if you let me use more fanciful priors
and likelihood functions you know lots
of stuff can be bayesian if
if you get to a free hand in
picking the priors conceptual point
about this model that's
worth keeping in mind
when i talk about the the belief about
what my opponent is going to do
i think i'm playing the best response to
it's like i think there's a two-thirds
of chance
my opponent plays heads and a one-third
my opponent plays tails that's what
matters for
today's play
but the updating depends on more than
that belief
knowing this two-thirds one-third number
isn't enough
it doesn't tell me how sure i am of a
two-thirds one-third number okay
so this two-thirds one-third is actually
the expected value
you have you don't know the probability
of heads and tails you have a beliefs
over that
so think of an expected value or an
integral over that that's what the
two-thirds of one-thirds is um
so we can compare these two different
situations with the same
one-period forecast either i am sure
that the all the other players
you know half of them play heads have
play tails so every day
there's a 50 50 chance of heads or tails
that's
case one case two i'm sure
every either everyone in the world plays
heads or everyone in the world place
tales
i don't know which 50 50.
so then in terms of what i expect to see
the next time i play
the two cases are identical 50 50 heads
and tails
but the updating is different because in
one case you expect
no matter what you see today you'll
believe 50 50
t plus one t plus two t plus three the
other case you expect that you will
learn
either its heads or its tails
i verbally told you the the rule for
fictitious play
i didn't bother writing it out in terms
of notation
well why because the functional form is
convenient but it's not
necessary for many of the of the main
results
and conclusions so these key features
are this asymptotic
empiricism and asymptotic myopia
thing to note in any bayesian scheme
beliefs won't necessarily exactly be the
empirical distribution
because you've got a prior the
asymptotic empiricism
just says that over time data swamps to
prior
so in the long run beliefs look like the
data
fictitious play i emphasized a few
slides ago
people think the world is constant okay
um that's wrong if there's a time trend
um if cycles persist
people might notice them i'll show you
an example of a cycle pretty soon
but at least the beliefs won't be
falsified in the first few periods now
some people
may have taken an undergraduate game
theory class and see the discussion of
cornell adjustment
car no adjustment every day you play a
best response to what your opponent did
yesterday
so it's as if you believe your
opponent's play today will be what your
opponent did yesterday
and when you run this process unless you
happen to start right at the equilibrium
it moves so this is a case where your
prior gets falsified
with you know one data point that's what
i would call a
you know too too extremely stupid to
find plausible prior here you think
they're all the stationary because
suppose it's doing some very complicated
low frequency cycle
so maybe you don't notice that wouldn't
bother you if it's a high frequency
sharp cycle i think you'd notice
if it's a strong time trend i think
you'd notice if there's some small
movement
okay so maybe you wouldn't okay
cycles fictitious play can cycle
um
old example suppose there's one player
one and one player two
they're playing this particular
coordination game
and i'm going to start off the initial
weights one and root two
so each player thinks it's more likely
his opponent plays b
than a so what happens
when the first period each guy thinks
the other guy plays b
with probably more than half so each guy
plays a
okay so that means we're here in the
first period
now what happens the updating rule i saw
you play a
i'll update the weight on a by one now
the weights are two and square root of
two
so a is more likely than b now it
happens both guys say oh my opponent's
probably playing a
i should play b and we end up here
and this process is just going to go
like this okay
so
this one you know couldn't take
seriously as a
prediction of play
nevertheless in this cycle the frequency
of play
converges to 50 50 for each guy
and that's the nash equilibrium and when
brown wrote down fictitious play that's
all he cared about so
brown didn't care about this fictitious
play work chair it
computed 50 50. um
it's not a good model of learning not
only are people ignoring the cycle
but they're getting zero every period
and by mixing 50 50 you can guarantee a
half so people are getting less than
their min max values people are doing
really badly um
please the reason you don't like that
cycle because
it's so short that people have to notice
it yeah
it's it's super duper short so long it
was a really long
cycle and that's well and the other
thing i didn't like about
this is people are getting less than
their min max payoff
they're getting really bad payoffs and i
think even if it's a long cycle
if on someone saw that you're getting
zero every day
and you know a simple rule that
guarantees you a half
you might eventually say gee this what
i'm doing is just not working i'm
i'm just going to go back to flipping a
coin and get my half
so those are those two the two related
problems here
it was not a constant sun game so so
brown so
so robinson doesn't prove anything for
this play
in there are people but in two player
games it converges
this is two player two actions two
uh zero sum yeah also the average payoff
goes to the min max value correct yes
well here just empirical strategies go
to nashville
what's the plan for 2x2
um the empirical strategies go to dash
as you see the payoffs
aren't the nash payoffs
in zero sum the nash payoff is the min
max payoff
no but even the i guess what i'm saying
that even if you record along the play
how much people are collecting by
playing the
falling pieces playing the realized
others payoffs also go to mid max value
okay yes
interesting slide um important facts
about fictitious play
if the actions not the mixed action but
the action
like a so if play converges to always
people playing the same action profile
every day that must be a pure strategy
nash equilibrium
if the time averages happen to converge
the joint distribution
must be a nash equilibrium so why
if two's marginal converges to like
some mixed strategy sigma two one's
beliefs converges it's sigma two
and if the sigma one which is the limit
of one's play isn't a best response
he could do something better so it's
it's a very immediate consequence of
asymptotic empiricism
so myopia has nothing to do with the
dear clay pryor
and all that stuff um
fine so i showed you the screw example
where people were getting zero every
period and min max was a half
the fictitious play behaves well and
we'll leave that vague for
a bit when there's infrequent switches
so in that cycle i showed you people are
changing play every day
so if infrequent if you look on a time
path of fictitious play
where there's infrequent switches and
there's a
formal definition here but
it says this switches are getting
less and less frequent asymptotically
then it's epsilon consistent so it has a
kind of epsilon
no regret property
and it also converges to the best
response dynamic
so something between there's a
connection between screwy behavior
and frequent switches or these
cycles and i'm going to develop that now
to start talking about how we analyze
long-run behavior of these systems
so heuristic discussion what's going to
happen in the long run
with fictitious play let the empirical
distribution of ice play be d
i t
then what is d i t
it's what it was it's t minus 1 over t
times what it was at times t minus 1
plus the update which is what happened
at time t so what happens at time t
is player i plays the best response to
his beliefs
so here i've simplified
instead of putting in beliefs i've put
in the empirical distribution
so that's not exactly correct at any
finite time but he said asymptotically
the beliefs look like the um
empirical distribution so we can make
this work
in the limit change time scale
the tau b log t
look at more and more
units of time lumped together
um and suppose infrequent switches
this is condition that as time goes on
play changes less and less often
so the play is more or less constant not
just between t
and t plus delta but tau and tau plus
delta so it's constant over longer and
longer blocks of time
okay so that rules out any fixed period
cycle
then for large t and small delta
we can approximate this discrete time
system
with the continuous time system
d tilde dot is the best response
to the opponent's distribution minus d
i and when that's valid we can study
long run behavior
by studying the continuous time best
response dynamic which is this and there
should be a tilde here as well i'm sorry
this is i just the
d tildes are d's in tau space instead of
t space
looking at this you can see with steady
states of a system
left-hand side is zero people play our
eyes playing your best response
to what's going on so steady states of a
system over nash equilibria
of the game and we can talk about stable
nash equilibria unstable nash equilibria
and so on okay
what's the role of the mathematically
what's the role of infrequent switching
um okay
we want to have this differential
equation so think about if the discrete
time thing's bouncing around really fast
every
every not pushed together that's it's
not going to be very differential
over over over small time periods yeah
yeah so so we want this give us a
heuristic
i'm going to show you a formal result
let's make things a little easier
i'm going to make things easier by
replacing best response
with a smooth function or i guess jason
tells me people call it regularized
in computer science okay so um
let's consider the exact same kind of
process but instead of saying
you take the action as optimal given
your beliefs you take a smooth best
response
to the belief so the smooth best
response is a function is
it's continuous you know it's it's an
approximation of the best response
function
is your question
a couple of advantages of replacing the
discontinuous best response function
with this
continuous function one is now if
beliefs converge
behavior converges because your behavior
is a continuous function of your beliefs
okay that wasn't true with the exact in
my school example
your beliefs were going back and forth
on either side of the half and
beliefs were moving very small amounts
and your play was changing wildly
from period to period okay so we just
move that away
um so it allows convergence to mix
strategy equilibria
the actual play what happens each day
can't converge to a mixed strategy
equilibrium in fictitious play
um this
discontinuity so this discontinuity i
think it's kind of weird
descriptively it's what underlies the
frequent switches or conversely
continuity gets rid of it
and it's technically awkward so by
making things
continuous we can work with you know
differential equations not differential
inclusions life is better
so the short answer is no but a better
answer is the model about to develop
let me develop it and then you ask me
what it means as opposed to trying to
anticipate what's on the next slide
okay i i i i will show you a model
okay um i'll show a couple of models
okay of of
how this would come from so so br was
the best response function
the distribution that maximizes payoff
given opponent strategy
br bar is my notation for a smooth best
response function
there's a couple of ways in which the
smooth best response
might arise one way it might arise and
maybe this is a bit
what you're thinking of is in the sense
of harsani purification
suppose each day there's a stochastic
shock to playerize payoff
so then the probability the player i
when his opponent plays sigma on the
side the player right place s i
is the probability of a payoff shock
that happens to make si the best
response
so you're so close to indifferent some
days your payoff shot tells you like
chocolate some days you like vanilla so
you pick one or the other
depending on the payoff shock so that's
that's one interpretation of this of the
smoothing
that's sort of familiar to economists
um you could also get smoothness
from indecision or ambiguity aversion
that's
that's the reason people might randomize
now
if i write down these smooth best
response curves i freehand them
they could be very far from the curves i
started with
and then their intersections might be
far from the intersections of the curves
i started with
but
if we make these random shocks small in
the appropriate sense
then these smooth curves converge
to the unsmoothed curve in such a way
that their intersection
is close to the nash equilibria of the
unperturbed game
so you're making these shots have zero
mean or something so
sure yeah yeah yeah yeah
actually there's the exact same doesn't
matter
the for the convergence thing you want
them to sort of converge in probability
to a small
neighborhood of zero yeah
um but i didn't tell you anything about
the exact
what happened for an arbitrary shocks so
don't tell anything about
how close the curve is arbitrary shock
you could add a constant and shift
things completely and
we only know that these curves look like
what we care about
when the shocks are small
because the shocks like you're right
fine fine
um here's a different way of getting the
shocks okay
um which is um
suppose that what players do is instead
of maximizing this linear utility
function
they maximize utility plus this
perturbation function
where the perturbation function you know
is concave
and has really really steep slope on the
boundary simplex
so it's never maximized on the boundary
of the simplex
then when you maximize this perturbed
utility
you'll have a stochastic response and
again again eva's question here's a
different way of making things close
if we make these perturbation terms all
close together
then the fixed points of this perturbed
thing
are close to a nash equilibrium so
there's different ways of
of doing the smoothing the canonical
example of a perturbation function
is the entropy function so vi is just
the sum of sigma log sigma i and that
gives what are called logit best
responses
is the same as quantum responsive
it's the same response actually that's
what people normally mean so mckelvie
paul free
some parts of the paper they use that
term for any stochastic response other
parts of a logit
but what people normally mean by quantum
response is load your response to
correct beliefs
i haven't put in the correct beliefs
part yet um
that's this so this is interesting
um you know so we can ask
what does it mean in terms of behavior
that people are maximizing these
perturbed utility functions
um so we have a paper with um
we had a that answers that question it's
more of an economics question than a
cs or game theory question are you going
to return to your
cycle example no yes i will give you an
example so
in stochastic a smooth fictitious play
beliefs are just like in fictitious play
all that's changed is we change the best
response to the smooth best response
okay
this is also the same as perturbed
father leader and
you think about learning average sure
okay so how do we analyze these systems
now we smooth them made as easy so um
the technical tool we can use to analyze
these systems is called stochastic
approximation
that lets us determine the long run
behavior of the thing we care about
which is a discrete time stochastic
system
by looking at a related deterministic
continuous time system so
both those moves make life easier um
deterministic seems easier than
stochastic and
continuous time so differential
equations are easier at least from even
difference equations
okay apply just to tastic fictitious
play
we can use this to relate the long run
outcome to the nash equilibrium
of the game um
i'm only gonna have time to talk about
how stochastic approximation relates to
fictitious play
but this is a very portable useful
technique you can use it for lots of
other things
including something i want to try to
tell you about which is reinforcement
learning model of psychology
so reinforcement learning is a model
where the step size
on its face is not one over t as i have
here but depends on the payoff shocks
you get each day you adjust by your
payoff
so how is this stochastic approximation
well because the system can be driven by
the empirical
distribution of what's happened so far
the empirical distribution of outcomes
is always going to be a one over t
system so anything whose behavior you
can predict by knowing
what's happened in every past period you
can
characterize with this machine
some definitions um i was encouraged to
not assume people
knew terms that christos was throwing
around
yesterday um so the omega limit set
of a sample path is a set of long run
outcomes
a point y is in the omega limit if
there's an increasing sequence of times
t
k well
along the sequence the state converges
to y you don't have to be
y but you get closer and closer to y as
time goes on
a flow on a space x is a continuous
function
on x cross r into x
where phi zero of x is x so this is
you at time 0 you start at x you're at x
y t of x says if you started at x
where are you at time t okay
and we require that we can compose this
if you start at x and run till t and
then run s more
it's the same as starting at time zero
and running for time t plus s
okay what is this x it's
assume it's a subset of a finite
dimensional euclidean
space and if you start looking at the
books on
on identical systems you'll sometimes
see the word semi-flow
so it's that it's just like this only
time can only go forwards
extend this flow definition to sets
so the image phi t of a is
we start at time 0 at any point x and a
where can we get to at time t that's why
t of a
and the variance set is a set where if
you start in a
you stay in a for all t so it's like a
no escape
set
and a tractor is a non-empty compact
invariant set that attracts a
neighborhood of itself so we have a set
a
we draw some neighborhood w
around it and we start anywhere in the
neighborhood
we converge to a
okay so consider the discrete time
stochastic system
these are vectors in rn
theta t plus one minus theta t is f of
theta t
that's sort of the the mean motion of
the system
plus a to t plus one where these etas
are mean zero noise terms
um they don't have to be um
iid or exchangeable they have to have
mean zero
bounded variance and depending on the
theorem you might need bounded you know
fourth moment or something
huh no not the sun depend it's gonna
import the applications
we're not gonna have independence so
this would be like a
marking here yes exactly it's a
martingale theorem as opposed to
standard level large numbers but it's
similar that's right but it's important
they're not independent does this mean
zero
these things are nuisance terms
that converge to zero almost surely
okay why put them in
this for example when we talk about
fictitious play there's a gap between
your belief
and the data and that's going to be
swept into nuisance terms like this
the idea um we have this
one over t step size so if we didn't
have any noise
we'd expect the continuous time limit by
that heuristic i showed you before
um now this
we have these shocks but the weights one
over t so
we expect by something like full of
large numbers the shock should wash out
as cost is the same it's not independent
so it's not leave standard a lot so
a martingale law of large numbers is
what drives this
this goes away and then we get a
continuous time system after rescaling
it's important these aided t's aren't
independent they aren't even
exchangeable
they can be changing wildly is but it
means they're just it's just the error
so first step is to show that the
system we care about lies in an
invariant set
of a continuous time process this is a
result of when i'm in hirsch
with probably one the omega limits set
of any realization of a discrete time
process
is an invariant set of the continuous
time process
moreover the set is compact and it
contains no
proper subsets that are attractors
so it's that means that it's connected
and it's quote internally chain
recurrent and that's that's one of these
these terms of art
in this literature i won't define but
this is almost the definition
um so but if you look at benign hirsch's
result in the paper they actually don't
have this nuisance term
let's just say it's easy to add it in
and you need to do it if you want to let
the beliefs not be the same as the data
uh what does that tell us well if a
stochastic system eventually converges
to a point
that point should be a a closed orbit of
a continuous time system a steady state
if the system converges to a cycle that
cycle should be
a closed orbit retains time system
moreover our discrete time system has
some noise
so um we should expect that it will kick
us
out of unstable steady states right the
team's time
system can have stable steady states and
unstable steady states
and you say informally usually all but
you couldn't be there anything kicks it
it goes away but usually continuous time
system there is no noise
our discrete time system has noise um
and it's a theorem and i guess i
suppress the details under under the
appropriate you know full support
condition on noise
you can't converge to unstable things
let me leave that vague and
let me tell you how to apply this to the
stochastic fictitious play
okay i'm gonna follow when i'm in hirsch
and assume there's only one agent on a
side
one player one one player two so that's
a bit of a problem in terms of my
motivation because i said we had these
30
people in the lab you're playing a
different guy each day if it's really
one player one-on-one player two
they're playing a repeated game so let's
ignore that
and do but i'm hirsch um
takashi and i've extended this to the
case where there really are multiple
player ones multiple player twos and the
first time i'll tell you about it
because there's one
open question i would like to throw at
you but we'll see
how far we get um the state space is a
distribution of play
this map f that was arbitrary is now
going to be
this continuous time smooth best
response function it's the
best response to the state minus the
state that's that's the mean
direction of motion the noise term
is just the difference between the
expected value of this
and what actually happens right so your
br bar says you play heads two thirds of
the time
entails one third of the time so in
actuality either you play heads or you
play tails we've got a noise terms
we have to have to put that in
um okay and we just we can just define
the noise term the conditional
expectation zero
but they won't be iid they won't be
exchangeable they don't need to be
so illustration two players two actions
each
then the state is just how often each
guy is taking his first action
theta one is often player one took his
first action theta two is often player
two's occur first action
the theorem says that what we wanna
study
is the continuous times system theta dot
is br bar minus theta which is just if i
unpack the notation
it's here's the evolution of the play of
player one it's
br bar one of theta two minus theta one
and then two's play evolves according to
br bar two of theta one minus theta 2.
we just want to study that system and
again
i'm sort of cheating here because i'm
saying you best respond to this
the empirical distribution and not to
your beliefs and that's where this
extra nuisance term comes in
theorem um smooth fictitious play
convergence of a nash distribution
in any game where the nash distribution
is a global attractor
for continuous time dynamics
sorry what's the definition of global
attractor okay so
i defined a tractor so a global
attractor attracts from anywhere in the
state space no matter where you start
you get there
i should have said um
so in two by two games with unique mixed
equilibrium
like matching pennies okay i just want
to clarify
the agenda we're pursuing right now is
we're
wanting to know when the simplification
of looking at the continuous time
process
uh is correct no we've done that what
i'm now doing is exploiting the
simplification and telling you
what happens so the theorem said
we can use this
machine to well
actually this
tells us that we can learn stuff about
what can happen in the long run
in our stochastic system by
understanding what happens in the
continuous time system
now the question is in various games
what does continuous time system do
that's that's where i am now
and um
in games unique mixed equilibrium so
that
best response curves had unique
intersection we perturbed them a bit
they'll be intersections very near the
old equilibrium play has to converge to
somewhere
near the mixed equilibrium if the
perturbations are small
how about in games with two strict
equilibria
and one mixed think battle of the sexes
we can both go to the opera we can both
go to football
or we can randomize okay um
what happens then well that priori in
dimension two you could have a cycle
it turns out you don't okay so they
proved
that in two by two games this process
can't cycle
it has to go to a tractor if you'll need
tractors for steady states which steady
states
does it go to um if every strategy
profile has positive probability at
every state
this is a condition on enough
perturbation noise that you always have
some chance of playing
every action and if
theta star is asymptotically stable in
continuous time process
then we converge to with positive
probability
okay the mixed equilibrium in these two
two games is unstable
we can't converge to it so in battle of
a sexist says
we know we're going to one of the two
pure equilibria
it doesn't say which one and you know
this probability is positive no matter
where you start
but obviously if you start with people
really convinced they're going to the
opera
then they'll typically play off with
really high probability
and with high probability you will lock
onto opera this is a system stochastic
even if you start off
really convinced and opera there's some
small chance you'll end up over at
football
ahead of time we can't say what'll
happen but we know we'll end up at one
of these equilibria we don't know which
and that's sort of my do i think about
the multiple equilibrium problem
these are different possible rest points
of a system
where will it end up it's history
dependent we don't know you go to one of
them
we don't know which okay
um christos mentioned potential games
yesterday these are games that where we
can transform payoffs without changing
best responses
to make them into a team problem so
everyone has the same objective
and in those games also there's no
cycles
so play has to go to a steady state
in other games the continuous time
process does cycle and i'm coming back
to nicole's question
so what does it mean that the continuous
time process cycles
okay remember the continuous time
process we brought in as a modeling
technique
to understand the discrete time system
and the way we got the continuous time
is we rescale time
so if the continuous time process is
cycling
that means the discrete time process is
cycling at lower
you know longer and longer intervals
right it can't be cycling at fixed
intervals we wouldn't have a continuous
time limit because
when we scaled it'd be chattery okay
something that's a bit unfortunate and
but true the cycles can be stable
and even you might think we put in some
noise people are playing randomly that
could break the coordination of cycle no
even with noise and even if ages move at
different rates
the cycles can be stable
so good i will
tell you a bit about this extension
please does such a continuous time cycle
necessarily imply
some kind of cycling you know it
necessarily implies the slower and
slower cycling discrete time
so you don't get spurious cycles ever
just as an artifact no
no no just look at that right here
yeah yeah it's both directions um
so as i said it's it's handy to have one
player one on one player two
but then it doesn't make sense that
people are strategically myopic
each guy should be trying to influence
the other guy so what happens if there's
a bunch of people in the population okay
so we have a paper that looks at this a
couple of different ways i'm gonna tell
you the most interesting model
guess the model it's a symmetric game so
instead of player ones and player twos
so just a big pool of players so we call
asynchronous clocks every day i'll pick
two people at random and have them play
okay so that means x posts some people
might play
more often than others and
it's i'm even going to allow people to
play with different probabilities
okay um
so what do we do well we use exactly
this
machine i was sketching for you we
derive a related continuous time
deterministic system
and say the thing we care about this
heterogeneous agent
fictitious play in the long run we can
understand it looking at this continuous
time
deterministic system it's a higher
dimensional system
we have to track the beliefs of each
individual guy
we also have to track how often each guy
is played because
how often you know how fast you update
depends on how much data you have that
if you've never played
you're gonna update a lot so it's a
bigger system but the same
idea and then we argue that if the
system is sufficiently well mixed
and i'll define that the next slide then
it converges to the case of homogeneous
identical beliefs so we let people each
person
plays different rates they see different
things at the start i might believe one
thing and jason believe something else
but over time our beliefs will come to
be the same and we'll end up doing the
same thing
so over time you know unless we have the
same beliefs
then basically we can use the the time
hirsch analysis to say
what are the attractors of a system when
people have the same beliefs
okay so that
the convergence the building things that
benign hirsch worked out
with one player's side extend to this
bigger game because first we go to the
case where everyone has the same beliefs
and then we go to the attractors okay
so this is the um crystal's mission
conley some of the things from conley if
you
you know a big space like on the plane
goes down to a line
lines on a tractor in the plane the
plane goes to a point when
you have these two steps we shrink from
the plane to the line and then from the
line
to the second stage okay so that's a
little
unfortunate and it's good for the field
it's unfortunate for me it's a true the
result's not striking
but it says that if we had a stable
cycle in the benign hirsch world
we added these people playing at
different rates and different data
it's still it's still a stable cycle we
so this this this kind of heterogeneity
does not kill it off
so what's this well-mixed condition
it's that the interaction probabilities
faced by different agents needn't be too
different
okay so i'll let p i j be the
per period probability that i picked the
pair i and j
so probably jason and i play tomorrow
with a different number p i j for every
pair
in principle q i j
is the conditional probability that i
play jason conditional on me being
picked
and i'm going to define a number delta
that basically says these cues shouldn't
be too different for different people
this is this is something that can be
one if we have disconnected networks
um it can be as small as one over m
minus one where m is the population size
and we have a condition in case we
define this delta
our smooth best response function has a
lipschitz constant
so it matters how steep it is
and our well-mixed condition is at k
which think of it's a big number and
delta is something less than one
k times delta should be less than one
so that's the condition that rules out
most interesting network structures so
a simple network structure be people in
a circle and you play your two neighbors
okay that's going to have delta being
capital
capital delta being one that's going to
fail this condition
so an open question is take exactly this
learning model
but look at it on a network that's not
well mixed
so then what could happen well maybe on
one part of a network people will play
opera the other part they'll play
football we could have you know
they needn't converge to all playing the
same thing so more interestingly
maybe we get some sort of standing waves
going on for the circles maybe we could
have
you know football opera could be
swirling around around the circle don't
know
okay i'm just about out of time
one thing i was asked to
relate to briefly i will do the smooth
fictitious play is universally
consistent
this is worth pointing out with a couple
of links with literature
we say but a rule is consistent along a
history
if on a history of play you're doing at
least as well
as if you optimized against the time
average of play this condition was
mentioned
yesterday okay
deterministic fictitious play without
the smoothing or regularization
is approximately consistent provided
the histories meet this infrequent
switching condition
which we also needed to get the nice
continuous time limit remember my screw
example
that was not consistent but it was
frequent switching
okay when it's not so in frequent
solutions not satisfied
players can do worse than min max
so i suggest two properties you might
want a learning rule to have
you might think the players would want
their own rules to have the weaker one
is called
safety which is that your realized
average utility
should almost surely be at least the mid
max payoff your realized average
utility so my example people are getting
zero
and by flipping a coin they could have a
half okay
a stronger condition is universal
consistency satisfying consistency on a
path you do as well as maximizing as the
time average
on that path universal consistency says
no matter what your opponents do no
matter what screwy rule they use to pick
their actions
you're guaranteed to do as well in the
long run as maximizing against the time
average of what they did
okay so
that's what's called no regret
okay note that
utility of a best response to what your
opponent actually did
has to be at least as good as playing
the best response
when your opponent min maxes you because
that's the worst thing you can do so
this condition implies this condition
that's a do you have an example of love
sure easy example um let's take
um battle of sexes
i'm going to min max 50 50 every day no
matter what you do
i'm safe you're
always playing opera i could put up all
the time and then better because if i
ignore the history i'm typically not
going to be
you have this property of getting time
average no matter what i'm not
in order to be consistent i have to
respond somewhat to what you're doing
okay so here's the formal definition for
people who haven't seen it before
of what there's no regret or consistency
condition is
um it says that the limb soup of a
difference between
what you'd get by maximizing against the
empirical distribution
and the average what you've gotten
should be going
to zero or at least bounded by some
epsilon
this does not require that players
detect cycles
okay just you you thus you get as good a
path as if you knew the average
frequencies
okay so if you're playing matching
pennies
and if your opponent plays heads tails
heads tails heads tails and you're
player one
you can mix 50 50 every day
um you're doing okay
you pass this test but if you notice the
cycle you do better
okay and there are many papers in the
literature
started with consistency and have more
complicated
no regret or consistency conditions
conditional consistency you could say
you better
check or even odd days different and
no regret on on different sub histories
okay almost done a bayesian
which is said the
behavioral canonical for economists well
maybe not for you guys expects to be
safe
and consistent with effect your own
beliefs you think you're going to be
consistent
the problem is universal consistency
asks
for consistency against anything even
stuff
you gave probably zero
universal consistency requires
randomization again think of matching
pennies
if i use any deterministic rule for
playing matching pennies
okay universal consistency i have to
do well no matter what your rule is
suppose you know my rule and you just
play the rule that beats my rule you'll
beat me every day
so we know we're going to need some kind
of randomization
to be consistent and this smooth
fictitious play
is universally consistent so it's a very
simple rule you just
take beliefs like fictitious play smooth
your utility function a bit
maximize your guaranteed consistencies
so in terms of computation i mean
to me this looks this looks easy um
heart mass collal characterized a larger
family
of no regret learning rules or
consistent learning rules
and tim talked about how price of
anarchy bounds
can be extended from equilibrium to
norograph dynamics
so i'm out of time
so recency is a thing
there's evidence for it
it's hasn't been looked at much formally
for the following reason
so recency means you always respond to
the last observation
well then we can't use this workhorse
stochastic approximation technique
because your beliefs are in play are
always to be stochastic even
when times huge yesterday matters
benim hofbar hopkins have the one
analytic some nice analytic results on
fictitious play with recency by taking
the recency all the way to zero they
look at a limit where there's recency
but there's
virtually no recency it's a sort of
continuity result
uh levine and i extend this no regret or
consistency
to the case of recency
but again it's only interesting for
small recency
and in some cases there's lots of
recency
people respond a lot to yesterday so
these limit results about what happens
when there's
infinitesimally more weight on yesterday
than two days ago
aren't so relevant um
we don't always see recency it can be
greatly diminished
by providing summary statistics of past
play so depending on the
recording tech devices you give your
subjects you'll see more or less of this
so how important is we don't know
relatedly i've assumed and you guys let
me do this
people maximize right empirically
people sometimes make mistakes
especially computing
conditional probabilities and that can
let non-nash play
persist even with learning again
how much it persists depends on the sort
of feedback you give the subjects and
the kind of computation age you give
them you give them calculators you give
them spreadsheets
they'll do better um be nice to say
something about the implications of
recency
non-trivial recency for learning in
games and here we come
i'll close with this there's a
methodological problem
more from my field than for yours which
is i'm not very optimistic
about formal analytic results for
learning systems with high recency it's
easy to do simulations
economists really are not very you know
simulation friendly
so you it's hard to publish a paper
whose main
um whose heart
is simulation us
we don't know how to evaluate them don't
know how to think about them so that
that's an
open methodological problem to think
about and um
thank you for being patient
you